hello everyone and welcome back to the
skilling open
uh we are in the finals and it's again
wesley so versus magnus carlsen and this
is the second match uh
if you remember the first match ended by
uh well
by a draw uh each player won every game
with the white pieces and the the second
match uh is a bit different because
magnus won the first game with the black
pieces
and uh then wesley retaliated in the
second game
um it was kind of a drawer's position
magnus was pushing too hard for a win
and wesley was able to uh to beat him in
that game
uh third game ended in a draw and fourth
game was a very quick draw and
neither of them were very much
interested in uh deciding the match
in game four so we're not uh in the
rapids anymore we're actually in the
blitz uh let me just
update this for for a quick second i
forgot to do this
uh hello there you go bird uh just
give me a second there we go
all right so the bird is updated so it's
a blitz game
uh and now this is the first game of the
blitz so wesley again with the white
pieces
let's see what happens uh opens with e4
and magnus again
uh like in the game uh that he won in
the car carl khan goes for c6 the karo
khan is on the board
we have d4 and d5 sorry about that
and wesley again goes for the advanced
variation of the carl khan with e5
with bishop to f5 by magnus and now not
knight to d2 like in the game magnus one
the previous video that we've shown but
uh rather knight to f3 so here e6 again
magnus closes the structure
and bishop to e2 we have h6 magnus frees
up the h7 square for the bishop
and the castles by wesley we have
knights to e7
and now a4 both players grab some space
on the queen side we have a5 and knight
b to d2
uh wesley is preparing to shift this
knight over to b3
uh knights to d7 and now knight to b3
and this is now a very nice setup
uh wesley is controlling uh nicely the
b5 square so magnus cannot push b5 he's
control controlling the c5 square
and uh the a5 pawn could become a bit
vulnerable so here
uh there is one game where g5 was played
in the database and the queen to c7 is
also a known move but the move magnus
plays
bishop to h7 is a known move so already
as of move nine we have a completely new
game
uh wesley continues developing bishop to
d2 now with a double attack on the a5
pawn
and the queen to b6 now by magnus uh
developing the queen and then now comes
h3
uh we have knights to g6 uh getting the
knights to
a more active square in the future you
might be able to bust open the position
with f6 but
wesley uh well wesley just plays queen
to e1 and now there's a triple attack on
the a5 pawn
and you can't add any more defenders to
the a5 pawn
so you should defend it the only way you
can and that's bishop to b4 which is
exactly what magnus does
and wesley now trades everything bishop
captures on b4
magnus captures with the queen not a
captures then you allow ideas like a5
and it's just a just a very messy
position for black
so instead after bishop captures and b4
we have queen captures and the wesley
trades queens captures captures and now
bishop to d3 so we get we get this
position
uh where it's uh you know still anything
can happen
and here magnus goes for c5 it's a it's
a very interesting move
now you could try a lot of other things
uh instead of c5 you could just castle
you could play as
played safely with b6 but magnus decides
to sacrifice a pawn with c5 or
or rather he was planning on winning it
back afterwards however but there's a
problem
because after captures captures and
captures magnus plays
rook to a5 and now there's a there's an
issue with this move because uh well
wesley can stop the grabbing of the pawn
and here wesley just played bishop to b5
check
so here he doesn't allow magnus to
castle it's hard to save magnus would
castle maybe he would just leave the
king in the center of the board and then
bring the rook in
however now uh we'll never find out and
also
uh the rook will will not be able to
capture the c5 pawn but i'm pretty sure
magnus said
all of this planned out because after
king e7 he's still preparing
rook to see it followed by rook captures
and c5 it doesn't seem like wesley can
stop this
however rook after e1 by wesley and now
rook to c8 magnus goes after the c5 pawn
but now comes the move
magnus probably missed in all of his
calculations and that's
c3 and now you see the problem if rook
captures then b
a c captures on b4 attacks both of the
rooks and
on the other hand if you don't do this
if you play b
captures on c3 then we get what actually
happened in the game so here magnus
captured on c3 but now b4
and now wesley has this monster pawn
chain here on the queen side the rook is
under attack and later on you're just
gonna pick up this pawn
uh with the roxy one real captures on c3
and b up upon
once again so here rook back to a8 by
magnus
and rook a to c1 with all of these pawns
on the queen side nicely protected
uh there is uh well there's not much you
can do here actually
so here knights to f4 by magnus uh we
have rook captures on c3 as planned and
now
bishop to e4 so putting some pressure on
the position
if the knight moves then the g2 pawn
will be under attack
but wesley says i'm not planning on
moving this knight anytime soon let's
just continue pushing here so a5
and now f6 magnus needs to do something
because
those pawns are coming uh and here
wesley just plays h4 he's preparing h3
to kick away the knight get rid of his
weaknesses
uh and g5 by magnus he needs the counter
attack somehow either either
through the g file either maybe maybe
along the h file
depending on what wesley plays so here
g3 pushing back in the knight and now
g6 and here wesley just trades captures
captures
and now not h5 wesley decides that it's
not dangerous for him to open up the g
file or h file so he decides to go for
uh h captures on g5
uh with check magnus recaptures and now
now wesley plays knight to h2 which is
extremely dangerous for him
as you have to be wary of this bishop
controlling this diagonal rook is coming
to h8 it could be
could be very dangerous so here even a
move like rook captures an e4
is uh will be very hard for black to
play knight d2 you go
after the pawn and now still you're just
gonna move the bishop and push those
pawns the two rooks
uh will not be able to do all that much
however wesley
played this knight the h2 move and now
magnus just jumps in
knight to e5 and already there's a
there's a lot of pressure here
we have rook seat e3 by wesley and now
rook to h8 so now you have to be
very careful if you ever move this
knight to a weird square just rook to h1
will be checkmate
so here wesley decided to uh to push
back carlson's pieces but
it comes with with a great price here he
played f3
and now magnus just uh well goes for the
trade rook captures on h2
we have king captures on h2 and now
knight captures an f3 with
check forking the king and the rook so
here uh wesley captures that you have to
give up one of the rooks so this is how
wesley decides to do it bishop captures
and
now c6 and here we have the first
critical position of the game
feel free to pause the video and try to
find uh a good move for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding uh you
know a clear
path through all this madness and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
uh it's uh either rook the h8 chick or
just capturing the pawn so this is what
you have to do
because for example after captures
captures in rook a7
white will not be able to start
immediately advancing those pawns
because if you push b5
uh this is this is gone if you push this
this is gone and now
black uh gets a moment to catch his
breath and start pushing his
own central pawns however magnus played
d4 here and now
this is a problem because d4 loses the
game immediately
however feel free to pause the video and
win the game for wesley now while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it once again congratulations as
it really isn't an easy move to find uh
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
rook to f1 rook to f1 uh with the idea
that uh
well you have to get rid of this bishop
and then without the bishop controlling
this diagonal it's
just an easy win for white problem is
you don't even have the option of
defending the bishop with the g4 because
white will happily
just gobble it up after g capture c
captures on b7
it's game over rook b8 let's say a6 and
there is nothing for you to play if king
is seven anything wins here
you can even play a move like a7 and
that's it real captures on b7 you get a
queen into the game
and it's all over rook or the queen will
of course be the rook there are better
moves but even this is enough
so here after rook to f1 uh magnus
decided to do it
differently he played rook to h8 check
came to g1
and now rook to h1 check uh the f2
square is available
for the king so it's not checkmate came
to f2 and now rook captures on f1
king captures on f1 or rather not
because king captures on f1 would be a
terrible mistake if you played king
captures on f1
then b captures on c6 and after the
bishop moves you just move the bishop
and you cannot
win this with white anymore because
after a6
you get e5 by black and now after a7
black just sacrifices upon the bishop
covers this square
and after captures uh it's just a very
easy draw for black because it's
three pawns each and not much to worry
about the the pawns are coming also for
black so
it would be it would be a nice draw so
here after rook captures on f1 wesley
said nope we're going to play bishop
captures on f1 and now you're not in
time to capture my pawn
with the pawn because the bishop is
hanging so here
magnus was forced to capture the pawn
with the bishop but now comes
b5 as the bishop is nicely defending it
we have
bishop back to d7 uh and now comes
a6 so uh creating a pass pawn
we have uh b cap bishop captures here uh
doesn't really do anything uh because uh
well you just push a7 you're gonna
completely ignore the bishop
uh in case you were wondering uh so here
just b captures on a6
uh we have b captures on a6 and now what
you play here uh
d3 by magnus if you try bishop to c6 it
doesn't really do anything just bishop
to g2
the bishop will either be traded or be
forced off of this diagonal and then a
a7 a8 win the game
so here after b captures on a6 we have
d3
and now comes bishop captures on d3
uh so this is a sort of a prolongment by
magnus king e5
we have a7 and now bishop to c6 kind of
guarding that
e4 square but wesley just plays bishop
to f1 and it was in this position on
move 44 that magnus carlsen resigned the
game
uh as the bishop to g2 is coming and you
will not be able to do anything for
example king d6 bishop g2
and now it's doesn't matter what black
plays captures captures and the queen
comes into the game
so after bishop to f1 magnus resigned
and
wesley wins the first game of the blitz
section and
what happened in the second game of the
blitz section well
magnus was pushing for a win he found a
very nice
uh way to grab a pawn but wesley was
able to equalize into the second game
ended in a draw
so by winning the first game of the
blitz and drawing the second one it's
wesley so who is the first winner of the
skilling open
by defeating uh world champion magnus
carlson in the finals
and for those of you uh weirded out by
the by the title
uh wesley so is also a world champion
he's a world champ champion in chess 960
uh so uh just in case you were wondering
uh but i didn't want to make it too easy
for you
uh so yeah uh that's uh that's the game
i do hope you guys enjoyed it
uh wesley really praised magnus in an
interview after the game wesley is a
true gentleman
uh he said that uh magnus was simply
pushing too hard and
this allowed him to to grab a few of the
wins
throughout the match as uh he said
magnus is a fighter and he wants to win
every game possible
he doesn't want to to grab a draw even
though he was for example leading
leading the match so kudos to wesley
and he he even apologized for slightly
ruining carlson's birthday as
you know uh yesterday was carlson's
birthday uh
so yeah once again that's the game
that's the coverage of this very nice
event i do hope you guys
enjoyed that as well i would like to
thank alexandros bazakis uh paul
schaefer
uh andre aragusa aguila maya and roger
stone for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day